hey you dirty bird sit back grab a beer
and some pickled eggs because we have
the latest episode of Castle Rock and
think stories here with a detailed
breakdown of the episode and what we
could be in store for this upcoming
season you're gonna want to stick around
because we'll be discussing the Allen
Pangborn letters the mystery CD and aces
connection to the settlers so let's get
started
we begin in 1993 Somalia on the eve of
what is known as the battle for
Mogadishu if you've ever seen the Ridley
Scott film Black Hawk Down you can get a
better sense of what happened from the
American perspective in fact later on in
the episode will actually see a
helicopter crash into the streets of
Mogadishu young Nadia and Abdi are
enjoying their lives but for Nadia's
mother she wants her kids to go to
America where it's safer especially Abdi
who is beginning to fall into the wrong
crowd when she finds Abdi has been given
a gun she goes to take it back only to
be shot by an American soldier in front
of her kids we'll get more into that in
a bit we then flash-forward to
present-day Castle Rock where Nadia
watches pop who is recovering from the
mini stroke he experienced last episode
it's no wonder we focus on these two as
their relationship is at the core of
this episode ace drives past joy who we
saw last episode cut by her mother she's
still sopping wet from the rain and is
approached by ace who offers to take her
home not where she wants to go right now
and kids remember never get in the
stranger's car
Jamal ass naughty if she's ready to help
out at the church where she offers her
services as a doctor to the homeless
this is the Church of the Incarnation
which played quite prominently in season
one we even have our first crossover
character pastor Drew in season 1 he led
his parishioners to teach Bible study to
the prisoners at Shawshank which Henry
Deaver used to gain access to the kid
chants breaks into Annie's home at the
behest of joy to grab her things a
particular note is the lock box which
joy has specifically requested we'll
find out later what's inside it but from
episode one we know it at least contains
a gun and license plates back at the
Church of incarnation Nadia talks to joy
about her predicament she can either
call the police or go back to her mother
but Nadia see something in joy and
decides to take her in we've seen Nadia
break the rules if it means showing
compassion like how instead of turning
Annie in for stealing meds she wrote her
a prescription back at the starlight
chances caught grabbing Joy's things in
his confronted by Annie but Annie is
quickly put in her place when chance
reminds her that she almost killed her
own daughter last night something any
struggles with this episode taking to
junk food and watching old movies like
The Wizard of Oz Annie storms up to
Nadia at this Somali Mall demanding she
be taken to joy this scene clearly
displays how hypocritical and he is
lying profusely to Nadia while she's
told Joy on multiple occasions how bad
it is to lie
needless to say any actions have landed
her out of a job so it'll be up in the
air whether she will still have access
to these meds
Annie immediately heads over to Nadia's
home looking for joy when Abdi pulls a
gun on her joy told him what Annie did
to her and Abdi's the type of guy who
won't take [ __ ] from anyone
a few beetles surround aces truck we've
seen them the last few episodes as well
as in the crypt beneath the new Somalian
mall whatever is down there has taken
ahold of a sand we'll learn a bit more
of what could be taking hold of him a
bit later on
aces creepily watching old home videos
which he tells his brother Chris is to
reflect on but to me it's almost as if
he's learning using the videos to learn
about his past since I'm not sure
whatever has control of his body knows
every
about him two other weird things we'll
learn about him this episode is his
ability to speak French an ordering of
red wine at the bar two things I
wouldn't really expect someone who has
come off as somewhat of a redneck would
know or do but let's also remember the
name of one of the plaques in the crypt
it's French
Damien oh quoi so my theory so far is
that ace is possessed by this original
settler more to come on that in a bit
at the hospital Nadia reviews pops
latest blood work and the news isn't
good
his last round of chemo didn't work but
there are alternatives a friend of hers
at the VA could get pop at the top of
the list for new experimental therapies
that is if pop is willing to undergo
them the chemo has already put him
through a lot and he'll need some
convincing to accept anything new but
Nadia will stop at nothing to heal pop
for her it's more than just saving his
life it's about redemption she could
never save her mother back in 1993 but
with pop she has a second chance by
fixing him she'll feel redeemed that she
was at least able to save someone she
loved the irony of this situation is
that it was him who killed her mother
aces dog goes nuts as he takes out two
duffle bags from his home we haven't
seen what's in these bags but my best
guess is that it somehow involves
whatever he's planning with his other
converts he drives over to the Marston
residence where his San and Valerie the
real-estate agent are waiting for him
they were both previously brought under
the control of whatever is taking over
this town
Nadia tries to get Chris to work on pop
accepting this new treatment because if
pop doesn't accept his death in her mind
will be her fault just like her mom's
pop visits pastor drew and asked for
guidance about the thing that's eating
away at him not the cancer the guilt of
not being honest with Nadia about her
mother
pastor Drew has an odd question for pop
if he does confess what does this
confession cost her it's this talk with
Pastor Drew that later causes pop to
burn a letter he had saved for AB de and
Nadia upon his death it was a bit tricky
to read but here's an excerpt from the
bottom portion of that letter quote I
came across your mother in a hostile
situation and things went terribly wrong
as they sometimes do in combat your
mother was a casualty of that the
burning of the letter signifies
refusal to open up the past believing it
better to let the secret died with him a
choice that will later come back to
haunt him outside the church the
scripture reads ask and it will be given
to you seek and you will find which
could align with pop story-arc the thing
he hasn't asked for yet is forgiveness
we also get this shot of Hasan waiting
outside the church and as we later find
out at the end pastor drew has been
converted and it's likely around here
that this change took place inside the
Emporium gloriam pop stands in front of
a wall of clocks a subtle reminder that
time for him is running out in fact the
very first shot that takes place in
Castle Rock this season is of a group of
clocks at the Emporium pop has decided
to hold an Irish wake for himself while
he's still living and can I just say I
love how the coffin is filled with beers
family and friends if you're watching
that's what I want
chance arrives at Abdi and Nadia's place
giving joy the lockbox and some extra
minutes on her phone so they can keep in
touch I also think it's a bit odd we
haven't seen chances parents yet but I'm
probably overthinking it joy is able to
figure out the code 1225 which is
Christmas stay inside we see the gun and
the plates but are given something new a
cd-rom with the date September 7th 2004
now this date could have two meanings
it's either Joy's birthday which matches
with her age in the show or the revision
date of the ravening angel the novel
found on the CD the ravening angel is
this same name that was found on the box
a young Annie Wilkes took joy out of in
Episode one this book has no author on
it so we can't be sure if this is
Annie's novel or someone else's but if
it is someone else's my bet is on Joy's
father and while joy buries the gun
Annie eats away her feelings while
watching The Wizard of Oz nadia finds
out that pop is eligible for a new
clinical trial but in order to get it
she needs his army discharge form
knowing that he likely wouldn't give
this up willingly Nadia sneaks into the
Emporium to find it while searching his
death she finds a stash of open letters
between former Shawshank Prison warden
Dale Lacey and Alan Pangborn in season 1
these two characters conspired with one
another to keep the kid locked up in
Shawshank which begs the question
pop know about the kid who is still in
prison there by Henry Deaver and I think
it's totally possible especially
considering this image here which shows
that Dale Lacey was communicating with
Reginald Pape Merrill there's also what
appears to be a charcoal sketch of eyes
and we know from season one that Dale
Lacey was fanatical about drawing
pictures of the kid I really hope
there's a great connection between pop
and these letters and the overall evil
that is taking over the town and these
just weren't put in there for shits and
giggles
Nadia is able to find the files but is
attacked by Lance and one of his goons
who have a message for Abdi but Nadia's
able to fight them off at pops lake tim
is caught stealing beers but pop is cool
and lets him go with a bunch even
filling his backpack up with more ace
tells pop that he's done causing [ __ ]
with Abdi while both the cop and real
estate agents stopped by with more
nefarious intentions
Nadia overlooks pops papers and finds
out he was deployed to Mogadishu the
same time her mother was shot he was
involved in operation gothic serpent a
real-life mission conducted by the u.s.
special operations forces to capture the
Somalian national alliances leader
Mohamed Farah Aidid at the same time pop
gives his own eulogy which isn't the
most heartwarming as he tells the guests
that fostering Abdi and Nadia was quote
she's another goddamn debt to be settled
remember last episode he offered to
adopt Abdi and Nadia to make things
easier for the business a thought which
caused resentment for Abdi because
imagine being told the main purpose for
this adoption was business it pop is to
change as a character he'll need to see
Nadia and Abdi not as a debt but as his
real children Hassan the real-estate
agent and the cop take out Timothy the
bartender and Councilwoman Pinto
respectively likely adding them to their
possessed cult run by ace we even get
this shot of Valerie eating an egg just
like Hassan did last episode nadia asks
Chris if he knew about the truth about
pop but as far as I know only ace and
Abdi knew of the secret a springs Chris
to the church where we get a little more
insight into what is happening he tells
him that Jerusalem's lot was first
settled by a special group of people and
says quote this land you might say is
still theirs
we know that hundreds of years ago a
group of witches or as pop calls them
Satanists once lived on the land but
they were later burned we've already
seen two burned bodies in the Marston
residence ace tells Chris that these
Souls defend the land they were promised
and that he's creating a type of
fellowship my best guess is that when
ace was killed among the corpses of the
settlers his soul was inhabited by one
of these satanic entities now hell-bent
on taking over the town as was promised
Chris is stabbed by his own brother but
he's able to fend him off and get help
from the pastor or so we think
the pastor too has fallen under this
spell telling Chris before he brutally
stabs him that they'll quote make you
good as new son it looks like whatever
goo bath the cop was put into also has
some healing properties and if the GU
can heal could this be a way pop can
cure his cancer and in our final
heart-wrenching scene pop tells Nadia
he's done with chemo he's given up nadia
confronts him about her mother and he's
at a loss for words the secret he tried
so hard to keep is finally out
everything doesn't seem to be going well
for our characters except of course our
main antagonist ace I expect next
episode we'll pick up with an E
storyline and uncover even more
Castlerock mysteries thank you for
watching please smash that cockadoodie
like button and subscribe I've got more
castle rock videos coming your way and
let me know what you thought about the
episode or your theories below you can
also reach me on twitter at things story
whitey until next time remember daddy
loves you very much